what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be talking about a
topic um
a little controversial i don't know but
i'm going to be talking about
fatphobic and is it okay to not want to
date somebody simply because they're fat
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily
videos okay so this is my opinion on it
and just so you guys know
there's been a couple times where i've
been denied for my weight
i've lost some weight in the past year
but i was
i was pretty heavy like two years ago i
was like
i don't want to stay in my way because
it's embarrassing but it was enough that
i would have considered myself chubby
okay so personally i don't know why
people are offended by this like it
really confuses me
okay let's let's take out the looks
which first of all i don't know why
people would be
why you're offended if someone's not
attracted to you because the way you
look
someone might not be attracted to me
because of my face and that's something
i can't help
like so i'm not gonna be offended
if someone isn't attracted to me for
something i can change
like first of all okay second thing
let's take the like the appearance off
the table your weight determines how
long you're gonna live
so it makes sense to want a partner
that's gonna live a long time now
i'm not saying that that's a hundred
percent you know skinny people get
cancer stuff happens but
if you're bigger you're probably going
to have more health problems just
speaking in generalities second thing
you're going to want to teach your kids
healthy habits so it's totally okay
to have a value of yours being i'm a
healthy person i'm looking for someone
else that's healthy so i can teach my
kids healthy habits
like like i'm addicted to sugar
like truly and if someone doesn't want
to date me because i'm addicted to sugar
and he doesn't want our kids to get
diabetes i mean
men i don't think think that far ahead i
think that's more of like a woman thing
um i think men just like like what they
see
or they don't um but it's kind of like
subconscious right
third thing is it's like a lifestyle if
you're
someone that's super fit when you hang
out with people you might go to the gym
or go for a walk or go for a hike
it's completely different from people
that go out to dinner go to bars go to
um you know one group goes out to bars
at night one group gets up at five in
the morning
it's not good for a relationship to have
completely different schedules
so it really confuses me
genuinely when people are offended that
people don't want to date them
like who cares especially as a woman
um like most women probably could find
and this is something i think i disagree
with with the man of sphere
most women at pretty much any age can
find somebody that wants to date them
now is it you know the option that they
want are they making the money they want
or they do they have all the qualities
they want no
but there's probably someone out there
in the universe
that wants to date you but let me know
in the comments if you guys agree or
disagree um don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and ring that notification
bell
i'll talk to you guys next time